foreign
s
there we go
all right today we are talking murder
podcast
Kelly's favorite
our true crime murder podcast all these
shows
is it psychologically healthy that's
what we're talking about today and I'm
going to tell you right now I'm gonna
make everybody mad so as the great T
Swift says Shake It Off already so here
we go
we have a culture that is obsessed
obsessed with True Crime
particularly women
Kelly is smiling
as though
I'm speaking directly into her soul
correct
I feel very seen right now let's just go
with that now we've always had true
crime stories told orally about Gods and
Monsters and quote unquote others right
true crime stories and storytelling in
general has been wired into us we are
storytelling and story making beings
it's how humans communicate have always
communicated we tell stories story is
how we make sense of the world and it's
how we participate in the world it's how
we experience things
without actually sleeping with the
neighbor without actually dying without
actually being in a car wreck without
actually whatever
is through story
somebody tells us a story this thing
happened we watch a movie we get to see
it happen but we don't have to actually
experience the full weight of that
tragedy or that ah but we get to kind of
participate when he went hits the
winning home run or when Rocky comes
back in Rocky IV and and wins or
whatever
we get to we get to be a bystander this
is how we are wired
and then modern media hits the scene and
we are captivated by serial killers
murder
Freddy Krueger Alfred Hitchcock all this
all the stuff right and it Taps into a
very natural very wired into us
um survival Instinct which is to always
be looking for threats
to identify threats to see them to be
able to predict ahead of time what they
might do what you might do this is what
makes humans humans this is the frontal
lobe right this is being able to say
okay if x happens and Y happens then I'm
gonna do Z right so it kept us alive
because we couldn't fight bears but we
could anticipate bears
we could strategize about bears
and then in recent years with the
proliferation of True Crime shows Alfred
Hitchcock Twilight Zone War of the
Worlds and then Ted Bundy and then NYPD
Blue CSI NCIS signed to the Lambs cops
Law and Order the line between True
Crime fiction the unknown the dark
Forces and your neighbor who looks nice
but might actually be luring old people
over to eat them and skin them alive and
use their skin as a dress
it all is getting blurred together
and fantasy and fiction and reality in
your neighbors and your co-workers it's
all turning into the same river right
all these different creeks and
tributaries are dumping into the same
river
and then podcast hits the scene
and the internet opens up a never before
Trove of interviews inside police files
interviews with detectives my dad my dad
got flown my dad's a homicide detective
for years and was a SWAT hostage
negotiator Nancy Grace flew my old man
to New York and to do a cold case and
when Nancy Grace's producers called my
dad like Hey do you remember this crime
he goes yeah that one still haunts me
they flew him to New York and he was on
the show right it was awesome
True Crime has become braided together
with celebrity culture and our ability
to to participate in a ringside seat to
what happened so think about when Ted
Bundy was on the scene there would be a
news article at six and then to get it
nine and then a newspaper
well now suddenly there's troves of Ted
Bundy movies Ted Bundy interviews Ted
Bundy poetry we can read it all we can
look at his pictures we can read all the
the transcripts of the
conversations you had with police police
officers we got it all right
and it's the ultimate rubber necking and
it's messing with us in ways we have not
fully metabolized yet so make no mistake
I will go to the mat with any
neuroscientist on the planet any social
scientist on the planet the media you
consume affects you it affects the way
you see the world the way you experience
the world and the way your body reacts
to the world
it's a great book by Dawn Cecil it's
called fear Justice and modern True
Crime and
Dawn writes by connecting facts from The
Real World with a fictional style
narrative format true crime stories
naturally blur the line between news and
entertainment
the melding of facts entertainment is
commonly referred to as infotainment if
you are a true crime junkie or a modern
a murder podcast junkie like I don't
know Kelly and Jenna
and their friends
you are being entertained by the death
murder investigation of something that
really happened packaged in an
entertaining way
that's crazy
and I think Kelly tell me if I'm wrong I
think the first podcast it was cereal
was that the first one that kind of set
all this off
uh yeah probably so that was the big one
that um kind of kicked off the podcast
so I met Sarah Koenig and like going
down like that felt and I haven't kept
up with it in all the the other Seasons
but I remember her she came and met with
my law students and was was a did a
great presentation but it sounded very
altruistic like she got
she got
um had a question and kept asking and
kept asking very journalistic Endeavor
oh I think so yeah now there was other
podcasts I believe before that that were
kind of one-offs but hers was the first
one where you're telling a story in a
10-week Arc or whatever but um yeah her
started off with the story that she had
heard about this guy and it was like I
don't think he's guilty
and then it just goes from there
but it's it's the music swells and then
the wait till next week it like uses the
best parts of Alfred Hitchcock in the
best parts of like friends and then a
real murder and it braids it all
together and we're like and what happens
and then there's that little bit of
could this happen in my town right in
this in my neighborhood Maybe
allegedly right that's my favorite
allegedly
um and so and then I remember being so
bummed out by S town do you remember
that one
yeah that was uh one County over from
where my husband's from so that I
explained so much yes it does but where
you went man hunting
um
but but listen here here's what's so
frustrating about that
I I waited through that entire podcast
and I got to the end and they explained
it and it could have been a 16 minute
this guy was doing this particular thing
I think it was smelting or whatever he
was doing and it affected his brain
chemistry right and he was mad he was
brilliant yeah
but they that's not how they told it
they kept me hooked for I'll say one
with that when I kept waiting like there
was going to be this big thing and yeah
there really wasn't oh man
okay so why do we consume this madness
why do we do this
some experts say
we consume these shows as a way of
quote-unquote learning or mentally
rehearsing what we would do so it's
about preparation it's a dress rehearsal
so we watch Silence of the Lambs or we
watch even and I know this is a true
crime but for a lot of adolescent males
it kind of is like the John Wick movies
okay so this is what I would do I'm
gonna bury all these rad Weapons Under
my concrete floor and then chip it out
with a sledgehammer and then ride a
horse with a sword down the subway it
all gets mushed together here or like if
Hannibal Lecter comes to my house ah
okay I'm gonna number one you're not
gonna do anything but so it's about
preparation it's a dress rehearsal
number two we consumed these shows as I
said earlier as a way of participating
pretending to get inside the head of a
murderer or a detective or a victim's
family without getting blood on our
hands it's the ultimate voyeuristic
um activity when we it's consumed in a
podcast it can be super powerful because
get this your brain creates the art the
actual pictures in your mind from the
words of the show The cognitive work
that goes into the imagination can be
very very powerful because your brain
draws from what it already knows and so
when it says things like in the neighbor
had a Shifty look about him
your brain will go looking for your
neighbors
it's different than a movie because in a
movie you see Robert England playing
Freddy Krueger and it's like oh that I
got a picture of Freddy Krueger
not so with a podcast with a podcast
your brain has to carry the cognitive
load of the story it inserts people from
your past remember that coach yeah that
coach was a little bit sketchy he might
eat children and it begins to craft this
narrative around people you know and I'm
looking at Kelly and she's like oh I
feel exposed
a little bit on that one but not totally
because I don't you do I don't see
people like in my world where I start
thinking about that
okay but you don't think about it but
does your body
and I realized I said that in the kind
of the creepiest way possible thanks
John Mayer
um your body I said that's so gross
um I don't know now Jenna says that she
does the um
like how I would how I would handle
myself in this situation and I don't do
that but she says she does yeah I think
I more so started listening to them when
I moved to Nashville from my home
because I was like okay I am a 18 year
old woman moving to a new city and one
I'm intrigued by like the cycle like why
do they do that like what makes someone
to do that but also okay what can I
learn from these stories of like Kayla
here's what not to do as a young woman
living on her own in a new city so you
listen to these as like research kind of
I mean like I know I'm never gonna wear
my hair in a ponytail when I go to the
grocery store because they'll grab me
from the back never you'll never catch
me doing that oh yeah things like that
incredible
all right so
this hey this is the reason why
um
in education why we ask kids to figure
things out because it develops new
cognitive Maps instead of just
presenting it to them in a picture our
form
all right so number three
some experts put out there
that people listen to murder podcasts
obsessively because they need to see
good triumph over evil um with all the
Mayhem and madness out in the world it
lets us believe a little bit of God
overcomes
except I'll say this every podcast I've
ever listened to
good never wins
there's it never ends well yeah I don't
see I mean
I don't buy that argument but no I don't
because I know that even when I listen
to
different podcasts I have to to take a
break from them I have to detox because
your brain gets kind of too into that
and there's all of a sudden you can't
find good
because even if yes they catch the
person there's still somebody murdered
there's still probably multiple people
and there's still this
you know what is wrong with our brains
what's wrong with people so no I don't
buy that as an argument
all right so here's what we need to sit
on
Cecil says that consumers of True Crime
are being exposed to a distorted picture
of criminal behavior and justice
so in a true crime I've walked into
homes where there are
unfortunately people have passed away
who have been who have died violent
deaths
there is no music swelling there's no
um like loud piano and Symphony that
that comes there's no ticking clocks or
dramatic pauses
it's this weight in the silence that I
can't explain unless you've been in
there
I've been an active shooter exercises
I've been in a building with an active
shooter on the campus
it is not like it is on a TV show it's
very very different there's a level of
Haunting that is unique and it is
weighty in a way that I can only explain
if you've been there it's why police
officers often hang out with other
police officers because there's a shared
weight they just carry because they know
it goes on in the in the homes in their
neighborhood in the middle of the night
that regular neighbors don't know
and so when you consume podcast as
infotainment when you consume murder and
investigations and police work and bad
guys and good guys as infotainment it
distorts reality in a pretty profound
way
it also decreases confidence in the
criminal justice system as a whole when
all you consume is
a 10-part series and you go to the next
10 part series and you go to the next 10
part series
and you look over the course of a year
and you've consumed 10 10 part series
you've consumed 10 trials that may have
happened over the last 50 years totally
botched totally screwed up somebody like
a police officer with a Vengeance a bad
cop whatever
it's really easy to let those things
shift your bell curve and suddenly you
lose faith in everything the bad guy
always gets away there's murderers
around every corner eating kids and and
you know murdering dogs or whatever
another thing um I have a cousin who is
a prosecutor has been for years and
she's talked about how
the rise of True Crime has made their
jobs harder because people expect that
there's we always called it the magic
printer when we used to watch yeah the
mass spectrometer and you know and they
think they know all these things now and
like well that's not real life so juries
think that they're more educated and
they're not and it's making their jobs
prosecutors jobs harder
because they don't have the evidence
that you see on TV and in movies and
those kind of things half most of it
because it's not real yeah those that
technology doesn't yeah they think you
just put it in the computer and out you
know the things yeah and it and so it
has definitely affected that because
people think they know more yes and they
know just enough to be stupid and they
know enough
Hollywood to then look over at the
police officer and say you all must be
incompetent idiots or the prosecuting
attorneys you should have done this what
about this right right
so I am Holy with all of my guts not
compelled by the literature that
suggests there's no correlation between
violent media and increases in all cause
violence
I also am going to expand violence so if
you tell me kids can play active shooter
video games for 20 years and there's no
increase in
gun violence cool
I don't believe that all-cause violence
meaning a body that is always heightened
a body that is anxious a body that is
depressed a body that is a little bit
sharper a little bit louder a little bit
more anti-social a little bit more
isolated I I don't buy that not even for
a second
um I'm wholly unconvinced by data that
suggests there is no psychological toll
or cost to mainlining this type of
entertainment I just don't buy it
um it might not make more violent kids
but it might make them as I said more
anxious more depressed more ADHD more
prone to iceling behavior practicing of
suicidal behavior these correlative
studies saying there are no problems or
in my opinion they are highly misleading
I just don't buy them consuming and
participating in violence is going to
have an effect on the way you experience
the world
period
period and listen we know from other
other academic disciplines the
importance and strength of Behavioral
models a picture of new Behavior Alters
our Behavior it gives our brains a new
map to follow
it's why initiatives to increase
diversity reputation and media is so
important it changes our feelings and
emotions and thoughts it gives us a new
model oh somebody who looks like that
could be an attorney I've never seen
that before that's why those initiatives
are so important
but those same media companies didn't
come out and say hey all the violence
that we put out here that doesn't impact
Behavior at all and these media
companies talk out of both sides of
their mouth we need to provide new
pictures so that we can give new People
Avenues for empathy for Behavior change
and ah that doesn't alter anything
it's not intellectually honest
and we know that when we watch the news
over and over and over again it makes us
more anxious more depressed more Angry
more rageful why in the world would we
think it doesn't apply to us so here's
my three insights and
Kelly you'll get the final rebuttal
here we go
there's a shifting of the bell curve
that happens
most people don't personally know
someone who's been kidnapped beheaded
and murdered or whatever happens in
these podcasts now we have murder
podcasts and horror movies and we know
so much more I'm personally convinced
after years of hanging out with police
officers veterans and First Responders
that it shifts our bell curve into
things that never happened wouldn't even
enter our mind to things that happen all
the time everywhere
and the data just doesn't bear that out
it makes our bodies more alert more of
the time podcasts this is number two
podcasts are a new technology that
affects us more than we know
we are over informed and under
experienced we have seen a million sex
acts on TV
that's probably a little bit uh that's
probably a lot but we've seen a lot
yet the data tells me that fewer and
fewer people are having intimacy in real
life
we see so many violent acts on TV
yet we have more and more parents who
don't let their kids go to their
grandparents funerals because they don't
want to bother them they don't scare
them and so we've got kids who have seen
countless murders and deaths on TV but
they've never been in a room and felt
the weight
of somebody in a casket over there and
The Grieving that's going on
collectively
they've seen a lot of sexual activity on
TV and they've never wasted an entire
movie reaching over trying to hold
somebody's hand
so there's a disconnect between what I'm
seeing and what I've my body's
experiencing and when it comes to
podcasts here's why this is so different
for all of us
historically speaking to be in a room
with Joe Rogan and listen to Joe talk to
his three best friends about really deep
and Meandering topics
for all of human history to be privy to
that conversation you had to be in that
room
so we have bodies that have evolved over
time to gather information in a
multitude of ways sound smell sight
touch eye crinkles head movement
shoulders up shoulders down all that
stuff is data for us we're having
interactions and conversations
and now I can just put in my headphones
and head on down the street or get on my
Mower and mow my yard or whatever and
I'm getting all of that insight into my
mind but I'm not there
that is changing the way our bodies
interacts with the information that we
get it's all new is it necessarily bad
no I'm not going to say that at all
that's one of the things we try to do on
this show we try to let you pull up a
seat to a table with me and somebody
who's struggling that's that's the
purpose of the show
but it's affecting us
it's affecting how our bodies Express
empathy it's affecting how our bodies
experience fear it's a it's affecting us
in ways that we don't know yet
three and this is something that my dad
told me I'll never forget this I was all
into horror movies as a kid up until my
my late 20s I saw every movie that came
out I love scary movies I liked
interesting scary movies I liked the way
they the cinematography way scared
people at like bad guys in those movies
I watched everything
and I'll never forget my dad walked
through one day my dad the homicide
detective and I was watching some
horror movie on TV and he just quietly
said something which is which was not
like him he quietly said
I just can't ever imagine thinking this
is entertainment and he just walked on I
remember being like ooh dad dropping the
truth bombs on your little
and then I started going into these
homes myself
and so I'll just say this the death and
torture and murder of someone the
complete destruction of a family I I
can't wrap my head around consuming that
for entertainment
um
and that's just me and so I know those
stories exist I know that there are
people working through them and from the
journalistic Endeavor like what you know
Koenig did Sarah did with cereal there
are journalistic stories that need to be
told about Injustice about things that
are going unseen things happening in
marginalized communities all that's
important
I don't know
it's tough for me to consume it as
entertainment
I'll pass it on to Kelly for the final
word
be so funny if you were just like go to
hell John no all I'm gonna say is for
those that can't see right now those
that are listening on podcasts John is
wearing a shirt that says the killers
that's all I have foreign